[Music]
oh
expectations for the final season of
game of thrones were higher than the red
keeps tallest spire but did it live up
to those expectations unlike the
previous seven seasons all of which are
certified fresh with tomato meter scores
well into the 90s season 8 is not only
the lowest scoring season on the tomato
meter but it's also the first ever
rotten season of hbo's fantasy series
and i'm sure some of you are asking well
how exactly does that work let's do a
bit of math while the average score of
each of season 8's episodes is a fresh
68
a number of season level reviews
published after the finale have brought
the overall season score down into the
rotten range everyone hear my words
bobby flay
is now my sworn enemy which means he is
yours now if anyone eats or even
recommends any one of that boy meets
grill
establishments it'll be agent meets fist
but game of thrones isn't the only
beloved series that critics felt whiffed
its final at-bat no matter what show it
is fans going into any final season are
hoping for the best and let's face it no
one will ever be completely satisfied so
we here at rotten tomatoes have gathered
a list of beloved series whose early
seasons were high scoring and usually
certified fresh but they all have a
rotten final season meaning that they
all received a large number of reviews
with many from top critics and a score
of more than 75 on the tomato meter and
whose last season or two descended into
rotten territory i destroy everyone i
love
i can't let that happen to hannah
to harrison
i have to protect them from me
we'd also like to know we've only
included series with robust scores and
we also also would like to reiterate
that this is not an indictment of the
included series but rather a
numbers-focused presentation of score
drops so which television series final
season has the lowest rated score find
out right now as we count down 10 great
tv shows with a rotten final season
[Music]
starting with number 10 you guessed it
game of thrones
while showrunners benioff and weiss were
never going to please everyone critics
pointed to the series penultimate
episode the bells as a prime example of
how a transportive well-acted smartly
written drama even non-genre fans can
appreciate could devolve into such a
divisive experience for fans the
critic's consensus for the bells in
particular echoes a common complaint
from the show's closing moments too much
plot and too little time muddles the
story and may leave some viewers feeling
its conclusions are unearned starring
amelia clark kit harrington lena heady
and peter dinklage critics say game of
thrones final season short changes the
woman of westeros sacrificing satisfying
character arcs for spectacular set
pieces and its mad dash to the finish
line
[Music]
oh my god
number nine arrested development the
first season of the formerly short-lived
fox gem is among the rare seasons
certified fresh at a hundred percent and
the subsequent two seasons that aired on
the broadcast network are also strong
with 94 and 100 tomato meter scores
respectively the netflix revival show on
the other hand wasn't exactly what
people were expecting at least the
series fifth season was a bit of a
second chance for the cast and creators
as season four's critics consensus put
it simply they've made a huge mistake
and though the series hasn't officially
been cancelled there's no word on
whether netflix plans to make another
season starring jason bateman portia de
rossi will arnett and michael sarah
critics say arrested development finds
itself back in familiar form recapturing
much of the cast's chemistry and comedic
brilliance though it still doesn't quite
live up to its own past so you were
stating as a fact
that buster pushed your mother down the
stairs buster says buster pushed my
mother and i think you pushed your
mother i think that mimi might not have
been the only person that took a fall
that night i think you let buster take a
fall for you oh i see so if i pushed my
mother down the stairs maybe i did this
too maybe you did i thought this was
about my mother it's about family all of
it stay on topic michael okay fine let's
do that where were you the night that
lucia lostero disappeared i don't know
where i was i don't know who was where
where were you
[Music]
so it seems that i came home from
somewhere the point is we're talking
about you not me well maybe we should
talk about you you were there you owed
her money i really need many hands i'm
sure
you borrowed it didn't you michael yes i
did borrow money because i care about
the family which i thought stay on topic
you bounce like a beach ball i'm
answering the question i'm saying
sometimes when you care about a family
or even a business you do some things
that other people might not understand
and what i might do are you threatening
[Music]
and and and and sometimes you do bad
things that you don't remember or i
don't want to remember michael's out of
control you're confident so maybe i was
out of control that night but at least i
can admit it admit what you're talking
like you killed lucille osteros your god
and that's how michael a few good men
himself i think
number eight sherlock
the first three full seasons of mark
gaddis and steven moffat's modern
sherlock holmes adaptations were all
certified fresh with scores in the 90s
but the 2015 christmas special wasn't
quite as well received and the fourth
season which came four years after
season three didn't make things much
better for the show starring benedict
cumberbatch martin freeman oona stubbs
and rupert graves critics say sherlock
makes a welcome and shocking return and
cumberbatch and freeman are game but it
may prove difficult to live up to the
lofty expectations created by the
series's lengthy hiatus
something's coming
maybe it's moriarty
maybe it's not
something's coming
we brought you back to deal with this
what are you going to do
whatever's coming whenever he's lined up
i'll know where it begins
enlighten me
we're going to have endless fun mr hopes
aren't we no
no not endless
a christ sanctuary look it's not a game
[Laughter]
you say you know what he's going to do
next
get out of my house
you reptile
the roads we walk have demons beneath
and yours have been waiting for a very
long time
number seven prison break
the fox dramas self-explanatory title
meant that the series was always gonna
have to fight against its own premise i
mean there are only so many prisons to
break out of but after a certified fresh
debut season and a second installment
that maintained the series propulsive
momentum per season two's critics
consensus things went downhill the third
and fourth season are both rotten at 50
and while the original series finale
delivered closure for fans the season's
ludicrous plot-breaking twists betray
the feeling that this saga should have
ended a jailbreak or two before fox's
2017 revival nearly a decade after the
series original end didn't fare much
better starring wentworth miller dominic
purcell sarah wayne callies and amari
nelasko critics say prison break
recaptures some of its old urgency in
its return but familiar faces and
frenetic action aren't enough to make up
for a plot that manages to boar while
begarring belief
there you are my man seize these dogs
that we can put them down
ramon what are you doing
you thought you tricked me
take the long way around
while your friend
gets here first to get weapons
you are going to screw me that's the
american slang isn't it you were gonna
screw me
so much for our word
lying to enemies
it's called aqir
take off the
camera i will show the world
what happens
when you screw
amur
on your knees it's not gonna happen
underneath
drop your weapons
step away from my brother
number six unreal
all three seasons of the dark bachelor
skewering drama that aired on lifetime
were certified fresh and brought renewed
respect to the female focus network the
fourth season however fizzled out and
went directly to hulu starring shiri
appleby constant zimmer craig bierko and
josh kelly critics say unreal's
narrative fizzles out in its surprise
final season but the clever antics
confidence and high energy remain intact
win send in roger so soon that was an
ambush what no quinn had nothing to do
with that
no one has had maya's back all season
you hear me
so if you're really her friend you need
to get her out of here right now
what
jay what are you doing
where's maya she ready to come you know
what i think i'm gonna take her out of
here this place isn't healthy no you're
not taking her anywhere
the only reason i brought her back here
is for this and the only reason i
brought you back is to make sure she
delivers so why don't you go back in
there and do your job okay
oh my god
oh my god
it's you
not quinn
you're my superhero rach
you know that you protected me
you
chose my happiness over ratings
but i can't
hold you in my heart if
you're gonna make your life's work
destroying women on national television
what happened to you
number five the killing per the first
season's critic's consensus the seattle
set slow burn mystery pursued by
homicide detectives sarah linden and
stephen holder started off with
thoughtful writing believable characters
and realistic horror even if its season
finale was unsatisfying by the fourth
season resurrected by netflix following
amc's cancellation it succumbed to
silliness starring marie enos joel
kinnaman greg henry and tyler ross
critics say while its character is still
intrigued and its atmosphere remains
absorbingly dark the killing succumbs to
silliness in its fourth season straying
into distractingly overwrought territory
why are you here holder felicia came
back on the stansberries
let me know what
uh
not if you're smoking
my house reeks
i'm done this time for good
yeah give you ten minutes tops
you might want to grab a shower before
we hit the road look look
wait so the gun
that killed dad mom and the girls wasn't
the same gun used on kyle
caliber weapon demonstrations on the
bullet
it's two guns
we just found the one
how killed his family got rid of the gun
they got another gun shot himself that
doesn't make sense unless someone stages
the suicide
block at the scene had kyle's prince on
the grip and
partial palm print unidentified
you never found the second weapon in the
house they've got that beachfront we
should get divers out in the water
already done mamacita
even minus my gel with the kiss of hemp
milk i'm a 1 900 rock star
you're in a good mood this morning that
i am
you want me to ask you why
sun's out got my smokes
the murder case worth working
number four entourage while the
hollywood antics of heartthrob vinnie
chase and his entourage were mostly well
received most seasons of the hbo comedy
are sitting comfortably in the 70s the
seventh season saw a turn as poorly
received as chase's fictional epic
medallion as the show approached its
eighth and final season the ending left
to many unsatisfied starring adrian
grenier kevin connelly kevin dillon and
jeremy piven critics say the familiar
faces are always a comfort but with
entourage's best stories behind it the
series finale feels like a merciful end
what's up boys
be done
you know i just wanted to see you guys
off tell vince good luck
and how many times a guy gonna get
married four times five times tops
a little help i mean i'm a millionaire
now you know i don't care if you're a
billionaire turtle you'll always be a
valet to me
what's up e i guess someone told you i
was moving to new york it wasn't me
really gonna go
a lot more to the story now like what
i'll tell you about when i get back
where's vince
on time and waiting anxious to get my
future started wow so this really is
happening huh well i like the ring too
much to not at least see how we are as
traveling partners vince venice hold the
plane
who's the broad
it's his wife you jerk off i can't
believe you made it listen i got a
stowaway if that's all right
of course
hi vince hi
this is sophia hello hello
congratulations thank you
nice to meet you congratulate you did
well for yourself you too so this is all
okay
it will be amazing you're gonna have to
find a new agent though you're quitting
huh i did quit and rumor has you did as
well well i guess we both got to do
what's right for the greater good well
you're not really quitting are you we'll
talk about it when i get back number
three true blood
hbo's vampire drama based on the
southern gothic sookie stackhouse book
series by best-selling author charlene
harris took a few seasons for critics to
warm up to it the show started barely
fresh at 61 percent in season 1 and
reached a series high of 95 in season
three but the third season's graphic
thrills steamy romance and biting satire
for its fans made way for a rotten final
two seasons as the series ran out of
steam and its seventh season felt all
too familiar starring anna paquin steven
moyer sam trammell and ryan quanton
critics say despite the promise of an
appropriately shocking series finale
true blood is mostly content to limp
along on familiar plot points i've lived
in bonton my whole life
and i love this town
and i've known all of you my whole life
and even though most of you hate me
i love just about everybody here
and i know what most of you think of me
that's some of you blame me for what's
happened
and you're not wrong
i played a part
but we can't go back to the way things
were and
i can't save
those who have been lost
but some of our friends and loved ones
are fighting for their lives right now
and for better or for worse
nobody in this town knows vampires
better than me
i want to help
please let me help
number two weeds
the dark comedy followed suburban widow
nancy botwin as she began to deal pot to
make ends meet following the unexpected
death of her husband and eventually
transformed into an international drug
kingpin and while the first season was
certified fresh and the subsequent ones
were generally well liked the eighth and
final season simply ran out of steam
starring mary louise parker kevin nealen
justin kirk and alexander gould critics
say mary louise parker remains a
mesmerizing presence but weed's final
installment burns the series remaining
goodwill down to a sorry roach with
perfunctory plotting and a sense that
this story no longer resembles the one
fans fell in love with
how'd you find me
2 year old house you're leaving i
followed shame
i was looking forward to one-year-old
barbecues burnt meat and toccate
i'll never burn my meat uh it's okay it
happens to every guy now and again oh
you're under the impression you could
just make a joke smile do a brick dance
and somehow
well everything becomes okay
work for me so far ah
we older
death is closer
we're going to work together again
you miscalculated blanca
you still think of us as the old nancy
and the old guillermo
those two poor
are so innocent they don't know that
they got 10 000 miles of bad road ahead
of them
we got no idea what's coming
man put down the gun coco no no no you
put down the gun i will blow this
[ __ ] take clear to glendale
guillermo guillermo i've seen the future
the future is in legalized pot you think
the chinese the vietnamese gangs are
tough corporations are the biggest thugs
you've ever seen i'm offering you an inn
you let us grow here
i make you a shareholder ground floor
forget guillermo garcia gomez criminal
now it's gear margarita gomez
board member get a foothold in on the
east coast and not with trey says you're
getting right
money's so clean you could
see through
[Music]
and finally number one dexter
seasons one two four five and seven of
showtime serial killer drama are all
certified fresh but seasons six and
eight plunged into rotten territory the
critic's consensus for season six counts
heavy-handed symbolism an unimpressive
villain and a redundant arc for
america's favorite serial killer among
the reasons for its low score while the
season 8 summary calls it a
disappointing season but perhaps the
show's revival series dexter new blood
will make up for its past rotten seasons
starring michael c hall jennifer
carpenter c.s lee and david zeus critics
say the darkly dreaming dexter lays to
rest once and for all in a bitterly
disappointing final season that is so
hesitant to punish its anti-hero for his
misdeeds it opts to punish its audience
instead
the hell is harrison doing with hannah
the deputy marshall pulled off the
detail it's not safe for harrison to be
at the apartment as long as saxon's
still out there okay then i'll watch him
but he shouldn't be with her that's not
fair to him
deb i have to tell you something
what
harrison and i are leaving soon
what do you mean you're leaving you
anywhere leaving miami
with hannah
what are you talking about
we're moving to argentina
are you kidding
do you know how stupid that sounds deb
you're gonna take your son move to
another country with a wanted fugitive
have you thought this through deb i have
we want to have a life together
i wish there was a different way but
there's not
we need to leave the country and start
someplace new
you act like this doesn't even affect me
i know it does
well then that's a really selfish
decision on your part we'll still see
each other
i'll come up here and you can visit
okay i'll look you up the next time i'm
in argentina deb i'm sorry
this is hard for me too
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you